serena williams has a baby girl who
already started playing tennis Justin
Verlander is now a Houston Astro and
grab your helmet and your shoulder pads
because it's week one of the NFL this is
sports without balls
[Music]
[Applause]
again everyone this is market alcohol
hey it's Aaron Foley host of sports
without balls were on episode 175 and
the man to the right of me was on
Episode one zero zero I'm like the
anniversary it's national treasure mr.
Tom papa yeah
hello America hello America hello it is
nice to be here with youse let me tell
you what's gonna happen today Trish Suhr
we'll be back we'll be back in the
studio on Monday she got crazy she had a
crazy work week we did grow the Dodgers
game last night
lots of sports and so I called when I do
sprinkle in balls I call mr. Tom papa
yes
[Music]
somebody complete that sentence job do
you enjoy sports yes I do what do you
think about our I love sports they're
doing so great right now
all sports are you oh my god did you see
the other night the other amazing oh
there was there was I was watching Vick
tennis baseball I was also researching
la roller derby I've been I went in deep
the last couple of days did you know
Cynthia's friend who did the roller
derby in the Santa Cruz area no Cruz
it's all the same area she they like
made a trip to go watch her do the
roller derby she's really good I forget
I'm blanking on her name and she yeah
she was really good and they all all our
friends like went up and watched them it
was a real deal yeah it's pretty good I
love roller derby and our fans have been
like hey wanna you cover some roller
derby and I keep forgetting and so
yesterday roller derby fans out there
because there's a big tournament coming
up I went deep with a little la roller
derby and I'm gonna report on it on
Monday where do they do it
well I used to see the Derby dolls play
it they had this that called the doll
house downtown LA where they had the
crazy not the flat track the I don't
know what the trip I don't know what
they called concave concave track that's
not what they call it and and then they
moved but now I also researched yet
another team in LA so I've got a lot to
report on that's gonna be Monday sports
fans what are you gonna see this well
they're there they don't play anytime
soon oh you're just gonna research but
I'm gonna research it because I want to
there's some crazy national tournament
November and I want to
oh well that's good I'm my own dime on
my own time close to sports well you
know what happens here's what happens
after we get out of the US Open which
we're gonna report on because I've been
watching so much tennis and it's so good
I can't even function then it's like
dude all dude sports you know we have
like wmba right now going into playoffs
mm-hmm then we have US Open hmm and then
it's like a huge drop off except for
women's like collegiate sports which are
fun yeah so I'd like to drum up other
sports that I can watch the ladies play
yeah
what about Australian rules girls
football yeah that starts up soon yeah
you know what the time changes
everything yeah it's because it's it's
their summer it's their summer it is
their summer so they all come outside
yeah yeah it's gonna be all dudes all
the time do you not like watching the
dudes want to sprinkle a little lady
sports that I always have to sprinkle in
I almost hit scribble in sprinkle in the
lady sports and scribble in lady sports
well I'm going to say that I think
you're a little wrong and I'm going to
correct you on your own show I think
gymnastics is kind of ramping up I think
you could watch on NBC Olympic Channel
new coming out soon
we've already watched the Nationals
Nationals yes when they were flipping
around doing their thing and yeah that
was to go to the next thing and that's
coming up and that's a lot of ladies in
it it's got a lot of late no you have
what I'm saying is you have to you have
to actively look and you can find stuff
because everyone just thinks oh baseball
you know I mean but yours there's a
whole other tier that you have to go
deep on Jeanette and then of course
we've got Olympics Winter Olympics next
year which is going to be so good yeah
it's ramping up and and there's always
dressage which is pretty much year-round
fancy lady horses with braids I don't
know that word you don't know dressage
no Romney's family did it it's a it's an
equestrian thing okay
some equestrians for some of your
listeners that means words jumps over
things and runs around and then other
ones they get dressed up fancy like the
horses the horses they braid their hair
and then they do like little fancy trots
and they base it kind of like a fashion
show for the horses it sounds like the
horse would really want to do that yeah
they're really really excited I don't oh
my god imagine if you're a horse and
someone's like we want you to try saj
and they're like you're like wait what
is that and like we're gonna braid your
hair or to put the tassels on your hubs
and you're gonna march around in a with
real which rich people from Connecticut
where we are right I guess like or you
could be one of the trail horses in
Topanga and you're gonna just sit in the
hot Sun and every once a while a tourist
is gonna come up we're gonna throw them
on your back and they don't know how to
ride a horse they're gonna pull it
you're bit always real fat and yeah
they're fat and you're gonna have to
just go over the same dumbass trail back
and forth all the time
well you made a really great argument in
fact for horses just came up no that
doesn't mean well five horses just came
up and they signed up for Jerusalem
massage is pretty fancy is that dressage
with an accent
no okay it's yes it's dressage with a
Connecticut yeah dressage so no but I
hear what you're saying it's gonna be
all do time for a while yeah that's why
I always like to you know pull in
pulling the lady sports yeah all right
I'm with you so we've been watching a
lodge in Essex that's the only reason
why not I make I'm excited do both char
and Lena go deep with the gymnastics no
just shy wow that's an inside that's an
inside news Tom and I have been friends
since 1960 we started out in comedy in
Florida it wasn't
yes it lucky lose it was a comedy club
and bowling alley and they had the best
fish nachos nachos it was like what's
under this chip and it would be like a
lobster or it wasn't really it was like
a scallop like a flapping scallop yeah
with its face the fact that we had to
kill the fish first was a little bit
much to get stage tearing that's why
they call it the do's Aaron that's why
they call it the do's you got a Pam if
you're gonna continue on while we enjoy
fish nachos I have been I'll tell you
about my last couple weeks of sports
okay I'm with you
we're both new yorkers mm-hmm we both
love New York teams mm-hmm and I rolled
I was on the road doing shows in
Hartford and Syracuse and then I took a
three-day reprieve in Rhode Island to
see my high school peeps nice and then a
week in New York City and I packed I
packed in Yankees Red Sox suite let's
start with baseball you were there when
they lost or when they were that series
they that was that was the beginning of
the good series okay we won I went on a
Thursday with my friend Mooney SH shout
out to Manish she's gonna be on the show
he's an insane baseball fan and it was
six - awesome and here's the highlight
of the game because of Aaron judge they
have the judge's chambers mm-hmm out in
right field which is so cool yeah
everyone dresses up in wigs a broom
boots and gowns and gets stupid
adult funds fun and we pass the we
passed it there's only maybe a couple
people because we're asked like we asked
them like do you bring your own you know
cuz I was like we have to check out the
judges channels and they're like oh no
it like comes this lady she was kind of
clueless right and she was like oh it
comes with the tickets which was very
confusing so I don't know full-on if
it's like a package thing I've got to
get some more information on this but
apparently you are given the
accoutrements when you arrive because
this woman was putting it on and she
definitely did not bring it and do they
match the other people it just was like
this
no some people look like they knew each
other so that was it we sit down and
then maybe to Eddings in it's like
welcome to the judge's chambers and it's
Sonia Sotomayor the real Sonia Sotomayor
who's from the broad and my head almost
exploded Wow what does she look like in
street clothes well she was in her she
was still so I never get to see her in
her in her lay close that's pretty great
yeah I I was screaming that's great and
the crowd went nuts and I thought very
proud of us that we knew who she was
yeah like Beyonce's mom yeah
I'm a little upset though that they
would hand it out that they would
because it's kind of like you know like
the Washington Redskins early where the
Cleveland Browns you know like you want
those guys to have their own stuff you
want their pig noses to be right right
real I bet no I this is something I'm
gonna write down Carole fact-checker
she's gonna do a little bit of research
okay so we'll get to it by the bottom of
the show or next show yes I have to
figure crazy New Yorkers have brought
their own stuff or it started with
people bringing their stuff yeah it had
to up there in New Yorkers are insane
basically you would think it I would
have to have started that way but I
could also see in the modern day package
they're just like yeah we're gonna start
a thing yeah which you and I hate to
bring it up because I know you'll
probably flip the table and storm out a
lot like the rally monkey town Anaheim
which I hate it more than anything they
were people weren't passing those out
that's what made it even more gross you
know what I mean people weren't just
getting their own monkey and doing it
when it's state sanctioned I'm not that
into monkey although I have to say last
night I went to Dodgers Arizona Dodgers
have just they need to get their mojo
back they are just there what's there it
was they scored one run in ten innings
it was a
but I did see gran key pitch for Arizona
that was cool that's cool this is a
weird time for them to be you want you
always want a slump in a championship
here but you don't want it in September
no and they think they lost I think
they've lost like 12 out of 15 Wow I
might have made that up but it's
something like drastic Carol what's the
last time when I say Carol I mean
Bretton by the way Brenton is in the
booth
Brenton usually is well he's a fantastic
stand-up comic and he is that might not
work oh my god okay Julie it's usually
Erin in the booth but Aaron is on his
honeymoon
and so our social media extravaganza
Brenton is now recording and he was just
saying earlier that every technical
problem that could go wrong has gone
wrong on his watch oh really
power outages yeah Erin Erin might have
that's really annoying my tits the
Dodgers Thank You Carol off throwing
your voice their last out of the last
ten they're 109 that's what survived
game-winning a losing streak I said 12
out of 15 yeah you were there
you probably well if we expanded it out
you're probably right yeah they look but
still 13 and but still that's bad and
Arizona's like and what about when
what's-his-name comes back when Kershaw
he came back he's back six the other
night so he's going to choke in the
playoffs again or will he be solid
because it seems like it's all joggers
momentum right now I'd be even with the
losing streak it just feels like that
kind of a season I hope I mean I you
know it's it's it's weird with the
Dodgers being a New Yorker like I've
sort of adopted them I guess but then
when you get to watch them at home no I
have DirecTV TV I'm not I don't get to
watch them I don't get to watch mine MLB
package I would get nothing once in a
while you'll get a Sunday Night Baseball
or like a Monday night baseball were the
judges wrong that's it I would have
adopted them I had a hat I was excited
for the stadium I was like this is not
this is really great and I for two years
have not been able to watch him so it's
like it doesn't happen right now
I just been you know Trish who normally
does the show she has season tickets
right so she brings me a couple times a
year it's fun to go it's just super fun
too going it's so close to my apartment
it's like literally seven minutes from
the apartment but it's it literally
living in LA which isn't that crazy
feels like being on a Rockies game you
know what I mean it's like yeah they're
just as far and as any other team that I
don't get to see you know what I mean
crazy I guess we should explain is local
Los Angeles residents spectrum TV only
covers Dodgers game so if you don't have
spectrum if you've DirecTV Dish or any
other network you physically get blocked
you get blacked out of Dodgers games
it's which is nice so I watched millions
of people crazy Yankee games all the
time every day I watched the Yankees
part of it every day and or at least all
the way across the country and then I
can't see the Dodgers that are literally
probably two miles from my apartment I
turned off the Yankee game last night
because it was dinner I was making
dinner for the kids whatever and like
this game's locked all right cool let's
not I literally set in my head don't
ignore your family and watch baseball
this game isn't locked let's just see
how the family and then they lost I
randomly we it was like the top of the
10th inning and Arizona put like two on
and I was like that's always such a
buzzkill you come back new tie it and
then you've got all the energy the top
of the ninth Jansen came in and like
locked it down then you go to the bottom
the night then you've got the bottom the
ninth excitement yeah and we didn't do
it and then the top of the 10th I
literally turn to Trish and I go this is
always like that tricky inning because
if they score like the entire energy of
the stadium goes out they literally
scored two runs and we were both like
it's like the biggest buzzkill yeah when
you're at home and the opposing team
scores in the top of the 10th something
about that you just know you're gonna
lose yeah let's pack up her stuff and we
walked we were walking out of the
stadium during the bottom of the 10th
like I know we're gonna lose and they
rained out tonight so wait when you were
at the at the Red Sox yeah where were
your seats that you were close to the
judges were you in the bleachers
no we we we went there early of course
because I have to go hours early but I
wanted to check out the judge's chambers
before because I hadn't seen it on it
but then we were who knew she had like
insane tickets we were like right behind
first base it was awesome and we should
you see that everybody had the Apple
watch on I did not I'm confused by this
story it is a little I think cuz my my
my level of tech is so low that I was
trying to figure out here's the story
folks
if you if you have not seen it the
Yankees just filed a complaint with man
Fred and associates who have done
nothing so far that the Yankees I mean
this the Red Sox are stealing signs via
an Apple watch they got one in the
dugout got the had the Apple watch they
signaled on the watch who signaled to
someone on the field who signaled to but
where the second baseman I don't get the
Apple watch part of it and this is
mainly because I have an Apple watch and
I feel like it only does a little bit of
stuff it doesn't steal signs like so
what would you but I what part d why do
you need the Apple watch I'm confused as
to the original who was originally
getting the sign you know what I mean
that's right exactly they must you still
need just a human being to steal the
sign somehow unless the Apple at the
catcher like this was wait I pulled up
the story and I read it and I still
don't know the answer
Boston Red Sox use Apple watches do seal
sign against the Yankees all right
Bulova blah okay so the catcher gives
the sign by using his fingers that catch
your signals I'm reading this from The
Times
number two picture to convey what pitch
he wants thrown of course right so he
does this little number thing and is in
his a ball area and then Boston decodes
the sign during the game the Red Sox
studied video replay from the center
field cameras to examine the series of
signs that the Yankees catcher used when
there was a runner on second base they
also recorded what type of pitches were
thrown so guy gives little signals the
camera in centerfield shows what his
hand movements are then they match what
pitch was thrown by matching up the
catcher signal with the type of the
pitches thrown they manage to figure out
how to decode the signs so they like
alright so that's a curve then the video
room sends the cracked code to the
dugout okay they send it they decode the
information to the dugout to the Apple
watch of a member of the training staff
and then he relayed the information to
the players in the dugout and the dugout
relays the code to the runner on second
so are the Russians involved single
pitch not a single batter benefited from
from hitting of course they benefited
the first series no I was just saying
that I was doing a joke off of your
right whenever they bring up something
you're like but not one yes the Russians
were involved but not one vote was
changed no how do we know that what so
anyway so then he signals so the next
time it batters up the guys on second
yeah he's signalling to the to the
batter here comes a curve yeah and if
you take the first series right cuz when
I when I flew into Connecticut my I'm no
clone in Connecticut my uncle is an
insane Red Sox fan
so I got off the plane and we got to see
about four or five innings of the game
he's in his red sock and weird screaming
at the TV and you know they killed us it
was like three or four games or a sweet
just match series yeah and like coming
back and I'm not saying it's all signals
but I'm just saying they play each other
two weeks later and we take four out of
five
so it's like a little I mean listen the
Red Sox are garbage the Patriots are
garbage
well how just a bunch of thieves in New
England what is it about I do love New
England but what is it about what is it
Tom Brady's and the Red Sox that are
always getting busted with these
high-tech they're either these scammers
air out of the football or Apple watches
is that crazy this is crazy though I
mean it just it's it's it's already a
team that I hate and then this happens I
know and they're like well everybody
does it
did you see their countersuit oh yeah so
they countersuit which could really hurt
them because they're not gonna find
anything and then they said if you don't
do like Mia culpa right away it could
add on to a penalty uh-huh but another
thing is the president of or the GM or
whatever of Boston he did like an entire
interview and he just goes he's whatever
he just he says so smug and he was like
you know so calmly and smug
I know there are animate but so calmly
and smug being like you know I've been
in baseball for 40 years and even before
my time people have been stealing signs
people still science it's a part of
baseball they still signs have you and
then he's like into the crowd with
reporters have you heard about people
stealing signs of course ever it's a
part and you're like that doesn't mean
you should steal signs and then he said
that the Yankees were using the yes
networks cameras to steal signs so he
was that he kept the counter yeah
Michael K is sending information to
cease involving Sue's mom is Apple
watching it down to Joe Girardi I find
it hard to believe
oh so the reason they got to use the
Apple watch is you're not allowed to
have no technology in the dugout yeah
yeah you can't have anything in the
dugout
so you couldn't just call our CB down
difficult so they had an Apple watch in
there oh yeah absolutely no tech but I
was trying to figure out how they
initially I guess someone you know you
can't because I was like well they can't
have a TV in the dugout so who's
watching the footage why is Boston such
such scammers God we need we need Muller
we need Muller to put a pin in the Trump
investigation and go right to Boston
sports whenever they say well everybody
does it that's what they always say they
always say but then why are you the only
ones getting caught all the time it's
it's it's just uncanny and it makes you
it makes you literally like everyone's
like Oh Yankees are like the evil I'm
like Boston spends more money right now
anyway yeah they are the evil empire and
they're using Apple watches
we're not Apple should go out of
business no oh
the Red Sox should be suspended from
baseball and we are in first place yes I
think the only punishment that lives up
to this horde horrible crime is they
should closes a franchise yes for at
least two more months no we'd love to
beat them up but I think you want to win
fair and square I mean this is just
stupid and it just makes you think like
so now they're cheating and now you know
Brady's coming in with his new bag of
tricks let me let me get a repeat no
they probably will let me ask you this
okay
let's say you're a player on the Boston
Red Sox or any team right I don't wash
my uniform my hat's gross yes and you've
got long gross hair and we're a
Republican and you can you tell a bloody
sock after you've made some terrible
business decision a smelly tuna fish and
you smell like tuna fish and fish and
chips are in your pants
okay alright so they're going through
this elaborate scheme yeah the video the
Apple watch you're on second base or
your hitter okay so you're a hitter you
get a signal like it's full-on like you
know this next pitch is a curveball yeah
like it's like it's just it just I just
feels like is there any morals sense of
competition sense of like I know what's
coming like what I want to know what's
coming
yeah no you know it's see everybody look
everybody does look for an advance any
advantage in all sports Yeah right
they're always cheating they're always
like doing what was the remember with
the Steelers when he when Roethlisberger
likes snuck the ball over the over the
line during the playoffs do you remember
that
Roethlisberger was like down and then
they declare that it was a touchdown and
he had like wormed it and they came to
him after he's like yeah I was down but
yeah we're trying to win the game yeah
we're always kind of looking for but
once you feel like it's the whole
franchise is in on it yeah and this is
like a well thought out with James Bond
Gamma bland yeah I I think the what I'm
trying to say is everyone's always
cheating and you so you always have to
police it yeah you always have to try
and catch them that is actually part of
the game as well yeah and also there's
just franchises that always like the
Steelers to me are there's always
something and I don't mind Mike Tomlin
but years ago on a Monday Night Football
the Ravens are spring to down eight
steps almost steps out onto the field
you remember that Breton you probably
remember that it's just like he's a big
Bills fan so huge those teams but I'm
just speaking for you but you don't I
mean you're just like what the [ __ ] you
don't mean yes it's just so bad it's in
the culture it's in the culture you know
who's not cheating and if they do it's
like old school the Cardinals right like
a Cardinals that's never been a
franchise that ends up like an always in
trouble I was doing something dirty it's
just like that's the culture there are
cultures when they say like the players
change all the time and
rooting for in there is a culture to all
of these teams
yeah and Boston is just the liars and
cheaters it's so ridiculous I can't
there's probably been some thing that
the Bruins have done I think probably
soften the ice or something they
probably do yeah now they're big fat
cheaters no but it was I was really
shocked like before the story came out I
was like how did we get crushed by them
like just two weeks ago and now we're
serious we like the game I saw well I
guess I saw part of the Saturday and
Sunday game I didn't see the Friday game
but I was at the Thursday game like we
like crushed him yeah you know I mean I
was like wow I thought we were gonna
lose three out of four yeah I do as I go
here we go and then we would Saturday
and Sunday I was like oh yeah and then
that's a huge thing because now I mean
that's the team we're chasing yeah so if
they were using this Apple watch
shenanigans when they were crushing us
three and a half games but also they
could be using it every single game they
played the whole season you know yeah
like I always go back to the only time I
was all-in with the Patriots was I was
all-in with the Patriots like this was
probably their first year they went to
the Super maybe it was like mm ladies
first two or three or something like
that against the Rams and I did not like
the Rams I'd still don't like the Rams
and I thought well you know and this is
before you know just the Patriots became
so evil yeah
I was all in with Brady and I thought
this was David and Goliath stuff yeah
Kurt Warner and the RAM saying we're
gonna kill him and I was in Rhode Island
at the time and I thought I mean just
visiting but I was like I'm all-in with
these Patriots yeah and then all these
years later it's like the spy gate and
the taping and he thought oh my god did
they tape how do to this day do they
beat Kurt Warner like that guy was like
screw 792 points a game all of a sudden
dirty you know oh god do I have to go I
mean you know some of the steroid stuff
was so it's so blatant in baseball that
you're like like listen I you know
Yankees in 2009
Abraham eat us you know I'm being myself
here he carried us and he was juicing
like a crazy man yeah so it's like it's
such a it's such a tarnish hey it is
it's all dirty but I think I mean every
single sport everybody is cheating
everyone
you just got to police the hell out of
it and if you're cheating so why does
Boston why his bail check and get caught
all the time like is it because people
are just really watching them or they
just sloppy and do it more than
everybody else let's say they do it more
than everybody else I think they do it
more than I think it's a combination
they do it more than anyone else and
people are now like yeah microscope
under the Patriots yeah
I can't believe NFL's I can't believe
the NFL start well especially when we
live out here in LA where mountains are
just bursting into flames from heat it
does not it's not even close I mean in
New York you were there right yeah 90
was getting a little cooler it was the
best I had a sweatshirt on when the
Yankees it was the greatest I was like
here we go the fall here we go
we won't wear a sweatshirt out here at
Christmas I was at the Dodger game last
night we left the stadium at quarter of
11 and I had a t-shirt on yeah which is
great and bad but it does not feel like
footballs come now until you travel know
until but it's coming and Thursday if
you're if you're doing your picks
it's got to be yeah are you playing are
you doing picks or fantasy or anything
I'm in this I'm in this pool where you
pick every game with the spreads all
season every week all games oh okay okay
all season and then at the end you can
win for the week and then you can win at
the end and at the and it's like a
hundred and twenty people and last year
I came in like fourth and often once a
substantial amount of money oh my god
that's awesome yeah what's the buy-in
[Music]
300 that's not bad at all no is not and
I don't know how I did it and the year
before I did really well so I'm well
ahead that's awesome yeah I mean $300
for a substantial pay out at the end and
it's really fun to do every to do every
one and you're gonna do it I do it
anyway like I I'm not I had to give it
up because it was ruining my life
that's fantasy or is that just picking
game oh I was picking at one point this
is like maybe three or four years ago I
did fantasy with a friend of mine like I
was basically helping you know anyway I
was just kind of like imaging it wasn't
like my crazy Rockford peaches baseball
yeah where it's driving me bat [ __ ]
crazy how I didn't even get what you
sent me well oh the peaches yet we're
gonna cover that on Monday Mike and my
fantasy baseball team is the Rockford
peaches okay and I threatened to leave
every year at sea or three and but Erin
judges my rookie so I have to play next
year anyway all right
it's my rookie keeper but I am I was
actually really disgusted this year
because everyone if you weren't in the
top like couple I was like I was in I
was fourth for a long time the top four
go yeah everyone sold out like every
team like six seven eight nine ten and
eleven gave all their all their cuz they
knew they were gonna make the playoffs
yeah every the first two or three teams
took like they're like alright here's
your first orange epic next year so now
they're super teams I refused to do it
but why do you why do you refuse if
that's kind of the way baby sports work
I made one move right right I made one
move and I got it I got a picture but I
was bleeding so deep and everyone was
kept getting at her I thought there's no
there's I don't want to you don't want
to sell out your future well this is
real this is stuff right
oh I mean I mean if you're a team that's
kind of on the cusp you're not gonna get
rid of everybody and I also I thought
you know this is what happens you get
you get like the fever right you get
like the you know what I want I wanna
you know I wanna I want
Grenn key and I want this and I'm gonna
give you around you know two and four
yeah right so then next year you're so
trap comes in you're so excited rap and
then you don't pick for like you picked
like three guys in seven rounds and it's
so awful and I just remember that
feeling I made a bad trade last year
yeah I would think unless you're really
confident that you start doing that kind
of stuff but then like the top three or
four or the the top three because I was
four then I dropped down to five then I
was four and now I'm six like you're now
you're getting killed you're getting
murdered by super team keep it this way
boys why don't do fantasy because I
don't have that kind of time like a
sides was picky
I just got to make sure I pick all the
games yeah and and if you forget or if
you're on the road if something happens
you just you're busy whatever you did if
but if you don't do it by the kickoff it
does it automatically
yeah the computer just you know
generates all the pics yeah the
fantasies a whole nother level of
involvement that it's deeper it's much
deeper the reason why I enjoy it with
baseball and I'm out seriously I am I'm
gonna do it like one more year and
you're not doing it with football at all
well the reason why I did it with
baseball is because of this podcast
because I didn't know any national
league like I don't know the Stars but I
don't I don't really know and I thought
it would make baseball more fun to talk
about it and it has it's been great okay
that's good just the maintenance daily
and and I get Virgo like crazy brain
where I hone in and I'm like I'm gonna
take that fifth pitcher of the Houston
Astros like no one needs to know but
then I get like insane brain yeah so it
kind of feeds that insane brain the
reason why I didn't do any fellow is
because a couple seasons ago I did I was
in my with my buddy in his fantasy
league then I was doing Meegan my
sister's picks for her office pool and
my friend Carrie spread pool and I was
like it was like a transistor radio I to
TVs I had a computer I could even enjoy
beautiful mine
I could encourage I was miserable I was
truly it sounds it was too much it's too
much
this idiot I was on the team but had Dez
Bryant I mean like the redzone flipping
on what sieves Dez Bryant is gonna catch
the ball I was like I quit all of it I
do love the red zone I can't stand the
red stone I I started getting into it
when my team's not playing yeah when my
team's not don't you go deep with red
zone the whole time huh don't you do red
zone the whole time if the Giants aren't
playing Giants your house and it was
like red zone red zone red yeah unless
there's like something that because the
Giants are the team I'll block off and
watch the whole game yeah that's my
whatever that's gonna be my big one for
the day yeah or the weekend and if
they're not playing and I'm just wanted
on and want to just kind of check in I'm
not just gonna throw on Cleveland in the
Jets yeah and let that roll throw on the
red zone and say yeah it's good the red
star drives me insane jets are the the
worst odds to win the Superbowl of every
team in the NFL you took 301 Browns Jets
that's the worst game exactly I'm not
gonna watch Browns Jets but with the
package I could go if the Giants aren't
on or a bi or Monday Night Football
whatever it is or like for instance this
Sunday they'll be playing Sunday Night
Football
yeah it's not so 5:30 for us I'll get
some football fever I'm not gonna lie
and I'll I will sit and footballs the
only sport where I can sit and
legitimately watch another game maybe
not the whole thing but most of it like
for instance you're watching earlier
yeah like Carolina Panthers right I've
been obsessed with Christian McCaffrey
that running back from Stanford I don't
know why I picked him out as I was
Winston says I'm obsessed his father
I watched 156 I was like wait is this a
wide receiver the Denver Broncos and I
was like how do I know this and why am I
not getting paid for this um and so now
I'm like I'm gonna watch Carolina on it
awfully good some Christian McCaffrey
and I also like I love
I love the dude yeah I'm a fan also I'll
start you know and then you know
sometimes I'll watch like you know
Eagles Redskins to get to know that our
divisional rival and you'll stay in
you'll stay in with this game I'll stay
in pretty far so anti red zone you don't
like the frantic only if it's like you
know if I see something with it's like
seven seconds left I'll flip on the red
zone yeah but I just like the I don't
know not to be super nerdy but it feels
like I'm more interested in like I like
the development of the play because then
I think well how are we going to beat
them how am I gonna
how am I gonna get an Apple watch this
might be the reason why I'm single
[Laughter]
probably you're probably right that I am
literally stayed up to 12 last night
watching Chris Anderson play Sam query
and a quarter finals of the u.s. I never
understand that though that's a bad you
know what I mean like you don't have to
find someone that's really into sports
as heavily as you are I know yeah all
you have to do is find someone who likes
eating snacks and wants to sit on the
couch reads a book while you're having a
good time right they don't have to be in
every pitch with you know just do you
like I don't want you like rice krispie
treats
there you go you like a nice nice uh
Afghanistan on the couch with you like
not talking to me for a couple hours
okay God's a dream that's all that
sounds like a dream that's all I'm
asking yeah no she just meant I'm never
like in public making eye contact is
emotional oh you need the person
actually come to your apartment by
mistake ring my doorbell that I don't
have I had a friend like that in uh
right out of college and he he wasn't
obsessed with sports he was a big giant
fan but it was mostly into the Simpsons
Oh
we'd and he would just smoke tons of we
bales of weed and watch The Simpsons
non-stop and then wonder why he didn't
have a girlfriend and we really like
literally a hole has to open in the in
the ceiling yeah and a girl has to fall
onto the couch next to you because you
don't have a chance of meeting her
anywhere it's pretty much it's 70% of my
life that a woman needs to be air
dropped through the roof edge shows
though I meet people you you're out but
he never yeah I think he's still talking
about Brian yeah I just I'm gonna I'm
gonna I have to say this is the first
NFL season in a long time we've been
talking about this where I'm just I got
so like I got really into I just the
last couple years I've just been more
into baseball more into women's soccer
I've been Oh ding on US Open I'm just
like yeah I think it's it's just the the
the the domestic violence and the and
the just the violence on the field and
then concussions something has been
aware that was I was gonna ask you that
like it's just that's a very real thing
yeah I mean this is a that last study
that just came out and I mean that's
yeah it's brutal and it makes you feel
like the game is total violence and on
and off there is all that element to it
do you think it's going to have an
effect or do you think that it's such a
gigantic business that it won't because
I believe the only thing that would stop
it would be money right I think so but
also I feel like there is this there is
I think it's starting at a younger you
know I don't see the end of the NFL is
is number one
football everybody loves football I love
football I'm watching football however I
was like an insane fan at if I'm like
kind of you know
and I remember growing up hearing those
helmet-to-helmet hits and you're like
yeah now you're like oh god yeah but I
think what's happening is yeah is is is
boys young boys now parents are going
soccer they're going lacrosse you're
going yeah and I I think that will be
that will affect I think that is I mean
those are conversations you're starting
here with all of our friends and their
kids yes and I know you're saying it'll
have some sort of it'll be a lot of
white kids that weren't going to even
play Division three yeah you know what I
mean well my father was it was big-time
football and even he is like I don't
want my grandkids playing my shoulders
are messed up my knees yeah stop his
head injury it's like and for him I mean
he that was like his religion yeah for
him this turn from it but he'll still
watch the pro thing yeah but he I just
think there's gonna be mostly poor
minority families that are gonna roll
the dice because it's their way out of
these horrible parts of these horrible
cities I think so I think what I don't
but I don't know if they're gonna like
change the rules or like really come
down on is there gonna be a result of
all of these horrible reports well also
I think also what's happening now in the
last couple of years that's being
reported and you can see it as the
tackling now is weird because they're
they're they're trying to avoid the head
at all cost
yeah and they're going low and now it's
knees ankles injury liked it what about
my dance career after this what about
obj like not even now probably he got
such a low hit a couple weeks ago that
we have Ezekiel Elliott he can just
literally have a suspension held up for
six games yet he can play against the
Giants you know explain explain that to
me I thought he was a crazy legal
loophole I thought he was out for he was
out but what happened was as far as the
legal mumbo-jumbo and I sent an email to
myself that says that I read that said
legal mumbo jumbo
but essentially
they upheld the suspension but during
this you know appeal I think that was a
player's union or his personal lawyer
both they did the like motion for a stay
where you see a lot in write regular you
know non-athletic law mostly murder
mostly murder so so technically meaning
like it's kind of a hold on the you know
they're appealing and all the stuff
right so so during that so then the NFL
said you know we like to give it's too
much in an advantage if if you just do
it like make the decision on Saturday
you have to make it before Tuesday and
the decision hadn't happened before
Tuesday's so they're letting them play
and then the suspension kicks in or is
it that it's a Sunday night football
game and you want your star playing or
is it that is it that of course I mean
are you [ __ ] kidding me
so now the Giants look pretty good
Elliot's gonna run all over us because
he can he can juice he can just just
literally do cocaine because he's
starting he's gonna be it's suspended on
Monday or we can do whatever no I think
we're at now I think we're add to Alice
yeah we're we're gonna get murdered we
always play well in dolls first game
honestly we're usually yeah their win or
we lose just at the very last second so
we'll see I just want to uh but can you
imagine suspended but but you can play
against the Giants are you kidding it's
gross just since that was always
happening whatever it's always happening
to the Giants it's I bet he plays with
an Apple watch oh my god I bet the the
Comptroller room a Fenway is giving
signals to is equally as Eagle be Apple
watch all right let's talk about
something good okay here's the question
for you
I went crazy deep in the US Open right
now as of a recording Madison keys my
new favorite player
she was up-and-coming and then had
double wrist surgery last year if she
beats her opponent right now there'll be
four US women in the semi-finals
not happen night it was like 2001 or
something only because they brought it
up yesterday I wouldn't have known that
yeah but it was it was like Venus Serena
Capriati and Seles I don't think you
should ever say that where you got the
thing from I think that's important part
of what you do the the anals of
impressive I probably would have gotten
three out of four I feel like you're the
person in school who uses big words and
then realizes oh I got to tell the
dummy's like I don't know I heard some
say that no it's impressive
I do I do love it I was jealous you
texted me the other day and said I'm
deep into the US Open and uh and I would
I was really was jealous because when
you can carve out the time to watch that
tournament it's pretty great
it's and I just have been not able to do
it I can do you know what I mean I'll do
I'll record it and I'll do parts of
games and stuff and it's it's what what
I'm Anna jam well you also have a family
time singles so that takes that's a time
suckage but with work those are my work
breaks I like work random hours and all
like like for instance well Madison she
was like kind of on prime-time on Monday
and I gave myself Monday night off cuz
it was Labor Day that's allowed but like
for instance I took like I wanted to see
I'll do like one set of one match like
this morning I had a ton of work because
I had a podcast earlier this and then my
big show at The Improv my monthly show
so I was like okay I'm going to take my
lunch break on the second set of Coco
van der heiße and then I'll watch that
so I kind of like manage it that way
because I don't have time to watch a
five hour five-setter yeah
are you the 10 o'clock show tonight
No 8 o'clock 8 o'clock yeah so you know
I'll do it that way but that's for major
tournaments it's only like you know 4
times a year so it's and it's it's open
and you know greatest it was awesome
those great ones with a Agassi while we
were living in New York oh my god they
were just great he just like took over
the town and it was amazing that was one
of the most bittersweet sports moments
is I was watching it was like a night
game Arthur Ashe Agassi Federer before
the roof right and it's a marathon and
Agassi was beating Federer and it
started raining and we waited and we
waited right and they never came back
out and the next day we could have gone
but I had to work in because if it
hadn't rained Agassi would have beaten
Federer yeah it was going that way that
was then we just got so hammered I was
in my friends like hedge fund group box
she made me drink she think it's funny
when you end up in like a sophisticated
place and then feel like gin and tonics
is the way to go because that's what
those people would have been drinking
and it just punches you in the face and
is like a serious gin drinker and I was
like this is the same Posse that we went
to Montreal to see the women semi-final
when World Cup last summer they can
drink like mother here's my tennis
question okay the tennis obviously who's
been fantastic and I say this every
tournament and I get real rattled up I
don't understand I don't understand
there is no part of me that understands
how they don't have they can't have
coaching every single sport yeah has
Golf has a [ __ ] caddy that's
like use this it's 20 feet away here's
the wind here's the Sun these guys can't
talk to their coach that's a good point
it makes me crazy why do you think I
would help them there's no the thing is
are you craving that coach do you feel
like they need I just think it is it is
such a solo intense in your mind sport
all you have is yourself you don't have
any teammates yeah and you can't have
any hope
but isn't that great isn't that what
makes it what you just described makes
it so just one then just one break just
one just one can I just talk to my coach
for 30 talk him for a second it's insane
because someone looked at their box and
they thought the coach said something in
there they got a warning and I'm like
and made me I literally was screaming it
was just it drives me insane okay I have
a solution what's the solution Apple can
you I can't I can't
it is something in sports that drives me
absolutely I kind of like it I gotta say
I like the idea that they are completely
on their own they are just it's the
drama I don't need some big tub of lard
sitting up there telling them what to do
I just so elegant and on their own I
want like one one like hey can I just
talk to my I would signal signals I
would have with like one numbers 1 to 17
and 16 is like approach the net or like
colors or like this this is like aren't
they from the baseline isn't-isn't
mr. Williams yelling stuff out from the
stands time and time well I mean it you
can lead our yet charger you can get
warnings and then you lose points oh
really yeah it's
I kind of like it it drives me I never
even noticed it until you started
solving it and now that you say only RAM
you made the case against yourself you
did because it made it so it makes it so
lone wolf intense I want to see him out
there I want Agassi out there in the
rain by himself it makes me hate golf
[Music]
not only do they have someone going
here's the angle and then they just have
a five minute conversation and what club
game yeah then everybody has to be quiet
so these [ __ ] can putt and drive in
total quiet it's a gentleman it's crazy
it drives me insane do you ever watch
golf oh can you watch it can you watch
the mate I can watch the back nine on a
Sunday yeah it's a different thing
that's here you know it just napping a
lot every other sport people are
screaming yeah about you're [ __ ] your
mother I have to remain quiet did you
read that in the in the Joe Torre's book
the Yankee ears it's such a good book
I'm not even done I it's one it's so
great that I stopped reading it at a
certain point and I'm like I'm gonna
pick this up again before next season
like it's but Wells talks about that
when he was in Cleveland and they're
yelling stuff about his mother oh my god
the fans are yeah and he is like just a
mess
and he's in the dugout talking to Cohn
and he's like do you hear what they're
saying about my mother
like he was it was throwing his game he
was off he's a complete mess in the
first inning and they said you you hear
what they're saying about my mom I was
like wow it really that affects them
like I would think they don't hear it or
they doesn't be yeah as a drunk he was
like your mom and it is Wells who's a
little more sensitive but yeah but still
like that's why I didn't think it would
have that kind of an impact like that
could change the game yeah some buffoon
just yelling your mom's or
I I would I I have a thick skin for a
lot of things but then I think I would
just implode Mary Foley's a-hole I'd be
like I would take a heater yeah and just
literally beam the guy in the stand all
right now let me ask this you're at
Augusta and one of the am I allowed to
play there as a lady no yeah you know
you're there as a fan and you're
someone's about to putt in you yell out
your mom's a [ __ ] do they ask you to
leave
yes they would oh god yes they would
come in they would come and escort you
on a heartbeat in a heartbeat oh my god
yes though it was try Oh funny who do we
who do we hate in golf Oh God
remember that dude BJ sing yeah he was a
dick Vijay Vijay
oh you mean Oh [ __ ] I had so many
jokes written for both [ __ ] sing and
you couldn't say any of them I knew I
said it I was like that doesn't Oh
[ __ ] sing man we when he got to the
clubhouse
it was heckle city but out there they
just never let you say a word it's
ringing with you dick BJ he was pretty
arrogant he was a misogynistic Pig I the
only reason why it just think you don't
hear a lot of random bad golf stories
because like he was he had really
inappropriate comments women like the
LPGA which is super fierce Cosby fan
huge loved his early stuff roofied his
opponents on the golf courses he ever
wonder why he's a real Walker see you
never woke up until Vijay left this
so we gotta take a quick left out of
that conversation all right one more
story and then we gotta wind it down um
I
alright so US Open where oh let's go do
a great impression of tennis by the way
okay do your impression of tennis while
look up a tennis I can't do I'm laughing
um this is a the US Open Andre Agassi
fighting off the ring he's ready to sir
oh my god it's pretty good right I don't
know if you ever said tonight but you
really need to do that I'll be at the
Comedy Store tonight I could do it as my
opener you should you should seriously
be like hey does everybody like
impression and then of course you have
to say it twice this is my impression of
15 Agassi 15 let us open and then pause
this is my impression you know it a Baga
see I'm so desperate for new material I
will give you $20
in fact and do it long make it a long
Valley I'm doing my gays are us tonight
you need to stop by between 8:00 and
9:00 third and just do all right I'll
give you $20 if you swing by the trio
and just do that impression and I'm
gonna scream up are you guys right for
something different this stage kills it
with impressions and then I'm gonna
bring you up and then you're gonna do it
then you're gonna leave it's gonna be
the greatest moment in comedy the only
way we would possibly work is if you're
just relentless and did it for three
minutes you just keep going and I'm
telling
[Music]
[Applause]
wait I've got an even federal you do
that on one might okay and you keep
going and then I'll do the announcer
voice on the other mic and I'll go home
oh all right it's almost we gotta hit
the field good over the week before that
WNBA oh god there's so many stories up
I'll save most of the stories for Trish
on Monday but let me tell you this I'm
gonna tell you that's real quick went to
the liberty last Friday yeah I texted
you where are you you said I'm in a
Liberty's game I said it's not the
answer I expected and that is true
courtside seats my friend Kate her
girlfriend it was on the wire so she
gets hooked up oh she's sort of knows
basketball but somehow she befriended
Isiah Thomas I was like whatever so I
get a text from my friend Kate rig that
says who's Isaiah Thomason do you want
to meet him I'm like I can't I can't
even I can't even so we go to the
Liberty game at the garden last Friday
we got the seats like second row I'm
losing my mind right now
it's Liberty San Antonio I get to see
all my Liberty players Bria Hartley and
Tina Charles and Kia Stokes all these
Yukon women is Applejack Johnson they're
Applejack Johnson sat out bad ankle and
and then on San Antonio side Kelsey plum
number one pick from Washington alls
time leading scorer NC double-a it was
amazing so then all since she gets a
text it's as a Oh Thomas is assistant we
go into the VIP area I'm like looking
around like oh my god and they call me
over there like Aaron meet Isaiah Thomas
and I I literally like I did have a
Roman yeah cabal legend I was like oh my
god peace a little piggy piggy he's a
little piggy piggy about sexual
harassment charge nobody's mad what a
big fan however you do have this moment
you're like holy [ __ ] balls
I can't believe you just said nobody
yeah it's Isiah Thomas no sex is
complicated okay stop talking
it was he was a charmer was he he was my
honey the smile was crazy we had such a
good conversation because I was letting
him have it because I was like I said
you know what's crazy about meeting you
and you know people blow sunshine up his
ass I'm sure twenty girls today I go I
couldn't stand you I said you were the
worst I was a big Celtic fan and I oh my
god I hated your team I was like now I
have to cheer for you because you're
running the Liberty I said Bill Laimbeer
is the coach of the Liberty I hated Bill
Laimbeer
so he was laughing hysterically you know
like a woman good for you good for you
so that was really super fun but you
have his hand on your ass the whole time
he was just licking my ear it was really
weird
um but he was really fun we talked about
UConn we talked about Liberty he was
really super gracious and fun I was
giving him [ __ ] the whole time it's
really fun but I had to tell you this
real quick
his wife was the coolest she came over
and cuz she's like John Starks just left
the room I was like I mean John Starks
John Starks and Larry Johnson were just
hanging out then they were across the
way I was like oh my god those are the
hate eight years of the next like well
you know when I was in New York and
there and she goes to two comments she
goes let me tell you this she goes these
guys they walk around the garden like
they're all that they didn't want
anything they didn't win one thing yeah
Alan Houston hundred million tank the
whole team yeah anyway frustrated so
frustrated so I'm dying laughing and so
and she and I said oh you know Nixon
Celtics and she goes uh let me tell you
this story you'll love this story and
I'm like I was like can I just talk to
you for five hours yeah and she goes
Isaiah and I you know we just lost to
the Celtics right we're at summer you
know we're we're relaxing by the pool
Isaiah's relaxing by the pool I can't
believe this right I'm like oh my god
she goes and I go to a Michael Wayne
when he go take a run and he goes I
don't want to take a run he goes she
goes you know who's running right now
Danny Ainge that is amazing the great oh
that's amazing
she's right she's right she's totally
right and then he asked me if I shot
like Larry Bird it was badass what a
great thing it was total but a nice
insight you just think you're good at a
liberty game which is cool but yeah all
of a sudden just crack into NBA history
crack it and be cool I was like you and
Joe Dumars in the backcourt of a god I
hated you guys that's great good for you
to be ballsy enough just to go right
Adam kiss your ass but no be we was so
fun you would have never done it if he
was an [ __ ] like he was a really like
really fun to have a conversation does
he do well with the Liberty pretty well
I mean we're in the playoffs yeah I
don't know how much is him but he was
really funny cuz you know how we draft
he goes we just whoever's comes out of
UConn we pick three players on their
team yeah but he was really lovely his
wife is fantastic very cool and then I
got pictures with that Kim Hampton and
Sue wicks
who I saw play in 1997 98 99 my head
almost blew it was the greatest this is
gonna come out tomorrow so WMD a fans
tonight we've got first round in the
playoffs
Seattle plays Phoenix I'm picking
Phoenix and Dallas plays mystics I want
the Mystics win I think Dallas is gonna
win watched em be MBA and then next
Tuesday the sparks they'll get whoever
wins round two it's really it's like one
and done for the first two rounds is it
really NBA playoffs or 17 months and we
get one and done oh my god but whatever
okay feel-good moment of the week did
you read this did I send this to you
which one um the female quarterback this
story I will post on Facebook but it's
just the cutest the the sweetest
awesomest
um her what is her name Holly Nair I
think I'm pronouncing her last name
right she comes in she is a school yeah
I think she's a freshman or a sophomore
a student at Hollywood Hills High School
she comes in all boys right she's the
only girl they think is the only female
they're like literally in the article
fact-checking this and if you go on to
espnW calm as I mentioned every week she
does this really awesome interview but
she was there down 21 to 7 the coach
puts her in the first place like a
running play the second place she scores
she throws a 42 yard strike touchdown
pass amazing and I think it's the only
like girl to throw a touchdown pass like
high school football history oh my god
that's amazing you know 16 or something
insane and she's cute as a button she's
5 - oh really
she played IMing what is it called uh
flag football right loved it so much she
asked the coach if she could try out for
the team she tries out for the team
she's like backup quarterback that's
amazing goes in throws a 42-yard strike
I once went to a Hollywood High football
game just like randomly during the week
yeah I was driving by with my friend and
I said I think getting ready to play a
game you can see through the fence like
you want to go we just went we were like
the only like people that were like from
the school watching it it was the
greatest it's so fun I don't remember
the team winning I do remember the tuba
players standing up when they what
little fans were there weren't excited
enough for him he decided to do a solo
on the tuba know those are the moments
you go for are the best those math small
fun
I mean local sports are the greatest I
would I always say I'm gonna go see more
local football yeah and never happens
for some reason well let's go let's go
at least you weed Notre Dame it's like
one of the best teams in this in the
country where do they play they play
right right yeah right
you where I live oh let's go yeah Friday
night footbed it's packed like Mike a
lot like it's a big thing I want to do a
Friday night football in text let's do
it but let's start in California I'm
alright alright blow off the show on
September 15
yeah let's blow that something to do oh
it's your birthday you guys that is our
show I know it flew by ah
congratulations to Holly Nair 42 yard
strike feel-good moment of the week
every lady that wants to play football
you can do it follow in Holly's
footsteps watch the last week of the US
Open potentially right now we have three
US women American and then we have
Federer and Nadal if they get through
the quarters they play each others in
the semis nice it's gonna be fantastic
and also I guess if you own Apple watch
to send those signals to the Yankee
dugout yeah get on board the Yankees
this is their run to the World Series
what do you think last last thoughts on
they're gonna catch the socks stink
though you think so I am they're gonna
catch him they're gonna catch him yes
the Boston will stop cheatin yeah yeah
Pedroia will have to put down his Fitbit
and the Yankees are gonna nail him we're
gonna take their game they're gonna take
it he gets so many extra steps crawling
up to his Keebler Elf house in the tree
that he's killing it unfair I do he's
the only one of the ends I actually like
what where can people find you Tom Papa
my podcast is to come to Papa and you
can find everything Tom Papa Tom Papa
calm and it leads you to whatever you
want bread-making
comedy podcasts it's all there do you do
it all you're a quadruple threat and
then maybe the fifth is the bread making
I mean you make awesome bread I had a
horrible thing last night I tried a rye
bread that was now flatter than your
notebook oh it was upsetting
I look could you get on it because I
love rye bread it's my favorite well
it's very humbling you master some parts
of it and then you like let me fix
and yeah and then you just fall on your
ass that's how I feel about dating yeah
it's very similar so you feel like yeah
I got this I got this and you're
watching sports at 2 a.m. and you need
to woman to be airlifted into your
living room so it's all coming together
Breton who's gonna win the Super Bowl
the bill the Buffalo Bills are gonna win
the Super Bowl you've heard it here one
of those next Monday with Trish Suhr Tom
Papa please come on again and again
again you're the best